there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello everybody its episode
145 yeah we got a good one today you
guys know we've been waiting for this
one oh I've had so many so many requests
to do this he's coming in here too but
yeah Alber fish yeah we've been holding
back on Albert because I don't know
there's a lot of Albert Fish shows but
you know nummy
again it's time we gotta get to Albert
Fish yeah I mean this guy I have a more
polished act we can do Albert Fish yeah
yeah
this guy man like I said when they talk
about the 60s kind of being the you know
the heyday of serial killers or whatever
this guy kind of predated all that he
was an anomaly this guy was super [ __ ]
up and I'm not saying that like I said I
write about true crime and I've written
about a lot of true crime from like the
early 20th century and it's a myth that
things got more [ __ ] up later on that
was they were just as [ __ ] that back
then but this guy was [ __ ] up even by
any metric anything you want to measure
this guy is completely if he appeared
today people would have been a gassed
ship that he was yeah that's what I mean
and it was weird about him is that he
was a killer but he was sadomasochistic
he would do bad things to people and
children but then he'd also do him to
himself yeah so like a tone for it and
it had a big religious element to it
that he would kind of it was like sex
and religion and pain and torture and
death and pleasure rape all kind of
mixing together he's just one freaky
dude and the other weird thing about him
too was that he was much older when he
started I mean he probably started
earlier than they are aware of but like
the canonical murders that they know of
he was like in his 50s when he started
doing those was that old I thought he
started yeah 30s when he was a painter
um he might have but like I said the one
who they know about
work from the 50s from what I remember
reading shows he was doing kinky [ __ ]
way back yeah when he's riding around on
trains yeah but I don't know if he'd
ever killed anybody does not come yeah I
do it weird yeah I yet they don't know
if he killed anybody until he was in his
mid-50s but he was for sure doing some
messed up [ __ ] before that but yeah so
this is a very special individual we
thought we'd save it for one of our
later episodes it's like I said this
this is probably one of our most
requested yeah topics we're ready to do
it so yeah so we'll get on set I don't
really have that many shoutouts today
I've been working on faceless villain
and volume three it is still on track to
come out in August I'm about halfway
done with it actually I've been kind of
plugging through like a chapter a week
which was what I was kind of trying to
do so if I keep we got a badass
microphone for it so the recordings
would be really tight yeah we just like
I said we just bought a whole new rig
with the old thing and like set it all
up yeah we got it's it's not even like a
USB one is it it's gay it's one that
goes it's an entry-level professional
rig yeah it's good enough to do audio
books yeah so we've been seeing with
this mic if you wanted to yeah so we set
that up inside the dead room so we're
using I mean we're still using the the
Yeti for the podcast just because I
don't want to have to like take down the
the good one from inside the desert all
rigged up but you know but this one
should be fine for this as we said
before I think the only thing only other
thing we wanted to mention was that this
past week before we were recording this
show we had one of our friend and patron
yeah came to visit us yeah turns out you
know she's a friend and everything we
actually had friends in common
her sister it Oh
her sister is friends with a girl who
was one of my high school buddies little
sisters we didn't know at a time but it
turned out you know I mean everybody
knew everybody knows it's like a small
world
you know yeah yeah yeah Michigan Beckham
is you know yeah one did a couple years
there you know
- in high school thinking then one after
I got out but of high school but you
know yeah it's kind of kind of a small
world yeah yeah she's got gal check we
went out to a club and then she went
back where she came from
yeah we took her to memento mori' it was
fun yeah so I'm super glad she came to
visit yeah she's gonna be back yeah I
hope she does come to we we were gonna
we are considered to having her on as a
guest
but she wasn't here long enough yeah she
was only here for a couple of yes
and we were you know bundle didn't allow
yeah by the time we got cuz you know we
were getting ready for memento and then
the next day we were all hungover and
slept all day so we didn't really get
much just kind of watched old movies and
yeah it's and late around the house and
somebody do themselves but it's you know
you made good stuff that's her thing you
know I was a first time I ever cooked
vegan food but you got it done
yes I think you acquitted yourself at
good I didn't try any of it but sure I'm
sure it was very good okay I've eaten
tofu another it's it's fine if you mix
it in with other things like I've had
spaghetti sauce made with it and stuff
like that and it's totally fine I'm just
so used to you know reaching for butter
yeah you know or you know tell me or
some cheese
yeah give me a piece of meat we'll put
that on it yeah I'm putting all the
meats and she yeah every time I makes
kind of Thompson every time I made a
song before I felt like it wasn't
finished yeah yeah should be some cheese
yeah yeah yeah you love cheese
well I was and also I feel like - it's
like every time you cook something else
just like you want to add like put some
cheese on it we gotta put some bacon on
it you gotta put some mayo on again put
butter on America's gonna put [ __ ] on it
especially from the south yeah means I
bought it if an ingredient is to hand
why not yeah I not put it on there
put that on it I'll get it she's told
many times you know I'll get I'll get a
sausage biscuit from like place like no
no Waffle House or something and I put
hot sauce on it
and grape jelly yeah so there's free
yeah that's right sitting right there
just put something on it it's good spicy
glaze well like I said it's like it
sounds weird but then you think of like
oh I've eaten like a Monte Cristo yes so
it's just kind of a similar thing and
that's a sausage sandwich man put some
grape jelly on it
well I can't eat because it's that's one
of the things I believe muffington I
never really liked um super hot stuff
growing up like I can handle like some
hot you know like I like Thai food and
stuff but not if it's just gonna like
burn your mouth and honestly now that
I'm in my 40s and it will happen to you
to kids you are not gonna be able to eat
things that you got to take with you
wherever you go you story much we're
going for a lot of tums let's have a
slice of pizza to burn yep just for
music that's what I mean I can't even
and I love tomato sauce and one thing
that makes me sad is that I can't eat
raw onions anymore yeah I can eat them
if they're cooked like if they're
caramelized but you know how you'd like
throw some onion like Ron Ian's on a
burger or something like that I can't do
that [ __ ] anymore just build it I'll
feel like complete [ __ ] for like a whole
day or two afterward i just bulldoze my
way through it I give a [ __ ] I just eat
it all I double down on it put some more
red chilies on that you know I just eat
it all and then I'll just whole handful
of Tom's yeah I don't care I would but
the tums doesn't seem to work as well on
me I don't think it works on me but see
sometimes like I said we have we have
like an Asian buffet that's around your
koi one yeah and we must be hungry yeah
yeah he made Thai food earlier so I'm
gonna have some afterwards I can have
like maybe two plate like I have like a
little bit of each thing cuz I just want
to taste like each thing and then I eat
like a lot of like you know cold shrimp
and stuff thank you
he will eat like five plates of stuff
he'll go back and get some sushi and
I'll go back and get like some ice cream
and I'm just like where are you putting
it well I make sure to get like a pound
and a half of that damn shrimp in me
okay I like the shrimp I can put a lot
of that boiled shrimp for some reason
you can just eat and eat and eat like
that well your protein and it just
doesn't fill you I likes pure protein it
doesn't make me sick or ash and
muscle-building protein sometimes they
have mussels or oysters to like and
that's you gotta go back to and we'll do
the evening but Fagen we get the crab
legs yeah man
oh they didn't have crab legs last time
they did not but they had a lot of other
seafood made this [ __ ] out of graboids
man I love seafood if it swims in the
ocean pretty much I mean within reason
if it swims in the ocean we have
anything else we gotta do I think that's
probably all that out today all right
now let's talk about Albert Fish this
mother [ __ ] also known as the vampire of
Brooklyn or the Brooklyn or rather the
werewolf of wisteria now or the grey man
or the boogey man yeah now for you
people on your commute in the morning or
the evening you might be in a subway you
might be curled up in bed and you know
what I mean with your headphones on all
right this is gonna be some bad [ __ ]
okay that's kind of like I feel like
that's all of our show this is gonna be
pressing this guy's is especially bad
okay yeah you might just be laying
around you might be doing housework or
something you know you know for those of
you new to the show most of our people
that listen to us or some kind of
commuter or they're going to sleep or
they're truckers or something so or they
listen to us while they're working
look my business why they're working
we're a time-killing tight show a friend
base show is the scene you know
everybody's friend
so if you want the facts get the [ __ ]
out of here just go to wiki there's the
[ __ ] of facts absorb that [ __ ] in about
twenty minutes mean there we're gonna
tell us but we're gonna tell you facts
but in a story type form and we're gonna
comment on the [ __ ] this is a show all
right
this is not a dry ass Wikipedia you know
Andrew you know talking about this is a
wet ass man the last time just last time
you dis Entertainment
we did somebody was you know people from
the people you know our regulars jumped
on the [ __ ] commenters they're like
15 mins I couldn't stand anymore [ __ ]
out [ __ ] we go that's what people do
that's what this show is about well
that's weird because I'm gonna take are
lots of other shows that are like that
too like a lot of them in the beginning
like they'll kind of like talk about a
bunch of other [ __ ] or like news stories
or personal stories or whatever and then
they'll get to the main topic and I
don't turn damn kids man they got
attention span of a gnat I can't sit
still ten minutes they don't have any
[ __ ] social skills you just want to
hear it real quick you know alright you
want to hear it murderer pedophile
cannibal Saint a masochist also I think
he ate [ __ ] out of here that's it just
and that's what that's what it is
okay but we're gonna tell you how it
went down there you go now you know now
you know [ __ ] out like it unsub alright
now that they're gone mmhmm yeah
now he was actually not born Albert fish
he was born Hamilton fish Danny born in
1870 and that's his fish sound like he's
[ __ ] rich born rich
I know only if his last name was my
famil t'n it should have been like which
people in the United States give their
children last names as first names
mother comes at you as Carlton or can't
[ __ ] out of here I feel like that was a
big trend yeah due to the girls two
girls named Winston are there any girls
named whistling I'm sure there's gotta
be at least one right girls name is
Smith that's a first name that's kind of
a rad name actually like that'd be a
cool it's not a cool name for a boy but
it's a cool name for a girl's first name
what seen some yuppie ass [ __ ] back
in the 80s but bourdette name yeah you
know what I was trying to be never from
Mississippi trying to be yuppie home
carpetbagger families moved away you
know went to college and never came back
you know yeah yeah okay
I was gonna say it's like because
because one of the coolest nism but this
probably just is me from growing up in
the 80s but we're that movie is a John
Hughes movie some kind of wonderful it
was kind of like pretty in pink but it
was like gender reverse um and people
don't remember it as fondly but I really
liked it and the really cool girl that
was in it she was like a drummer and she
was kind of a punk rocker chick and her
name was watts and I thought that was
really cool I don't know if that was a
real name or if that was her last name
or whatever but that was the character's
name in the oh my gosh people and I
thought that she wasn't posh though she
was like she was like a trashy pom-pom
chick that's why I liked her okay all
right so Hamilton fish record Esquire
whatever Hamilton fish okay yeah like I
said he needs some hyphenation go that
was like Headington fish halibut that
was the beginning of this man's problems
I think that damn name well Hamilton
fish the first of many yeah right the
first of many now he was actually born
in Washington DC his dad um I think his
dad started out as like a [ __ ] was
but he but he was 43 years older than
his mom damn dude talk about Robin to
crate that's what I mean that's him like
grandpa he's either robbing the cradle
or she's robbing the grave one of the
two well why not both yes so Hamilton
fish a better known as Albert fish was
actually the youngest kid he had three
older siblings who lived he had a bunch
of siblings that died also now because
he later on he got sent to an orphanage
which I'll get into in a minute
but because his first name was Hamilton
even back in the in the [ __ ] late
1800s kids were [ __ ] and they
started calling him ham and eggs ham and
eggs which that's actually pretty good
actually I thought like that's that's
that's yeah that's pretty mild for a
smiley and goes yeah but um yeah so he
didn't like it so he decided to adopt in
the name of Albert which I think was the
name of one of his brothers that had
died like in childbirth or something
like that
now again
aside from just the name ole ham and
eggs fish which yeah now before this kid
was even born I mean this family had an
extensive history of mental illness and
those lemis I found this one site that
kind of catalogued like all of the
relatives of his that had mental
illnesses okay his mom was for sure a
nut I'm not sure what she had might have
been schizophrenia but she definitely
had like auditory and visual
hallucinations yeah also had an uncle I
think it was his paternal uncle had
religious mania boy that's starting to
sound outward himself because that
Albert would do and complain about
sounded like very mild schizophrenia he
may have had a little bit of that well
yeah like I said if it ran in the family
that for sure because it seemed like
most of his relatives had something
wrong with them run I mean he had an
aunt one of his sisters he had a
half-brother that all had undisclosed
mental illnesses he had a younger
brother that was quote unquote unquote
feeble-minded and died of hydrocephalus
he had another brother it was an
alcoholic
and the things is that nature like I
said and his mom was also kind of an
that now his dad which like I said just
a minute ago I could remember what his
job was but he was actually a riverboat
captain but by the time that Albert fish
was born he was doing some other [ __ ] he
was like making fertilizer or something
now Albert fish's dad dropped dead when
Albert was I think only five years old I
mean this is an old dude you know like I
said the dad was 43 years older than the
mouth so after the dad died the mom was
like well I just can't deal with it and
put Albert into an orphanage I think it
was called st. John's now while he was
in the orphanage apparently this was one
of those you know 18 and late
18-hundreds orphanages where it's like
hey let's just beat the kids yeah so
they were all you know severely beaten
and whipped all the other kids like were
cruel and made fun of him and stuff this
is when he changed his name like I said
it's my understanding a lot of those
schools that were like that also like
like you would figure the track
a bunch of damn pedophiles they start
working there as staff and they did all
them children gentlemen the [ __ ] out of
them children
well yes terrible I mean that's yeah
well yeah there's wide open back then
because people couldn't even imagine
imagine it yeah I mean it if you were a
predator you would know exactly we're
gonna go I mean just like they do
nowadays it's just that nowadays
thankfully we're we know to like look
out for that kind of [ __ ] I think back
then back then they didn't really seem
to the more innocent time and also naive
and they also they didn't have concepts
like childhood then yeah have you guys
watching that on the last show here give
you could talk and and you could go to
work and you could walk around it's like
hey down the coalmine kid if you could
work than [ __ ] you can [ __ ] yeah this I
think how they thought well yeah I don't
think there would be any reason for them
to stop you know you know they're like
if you can like do a job the religions
were saying you well you can marry a
girl at 12 yeah and you know maybe Moses
married somebody at 10 or some [ __ ] like
that then yeah you can marry somebody at
10 once she's got her period in America
yeah so it was a different time the good
old days yeah I was being facetious yeah
in case anybody like what stick man I
was like what do you mean that was the
good old days that was terrible I'm like
yes I know it was terrible [ __ ] back
then man hear weird terrible yeah so
while he was at this orphanage like I
said and all these kids are getting you
know whipped and beaten and stuff albert
decides well he realizes that he not
only enjoys seeing other boys getting
whipped and beaten he also enjoys
getting whipped and beaten himself these
are very early developing some
sadomasochistic tendencies yeah now in
1879 fetishes and fetishes yes and
there's definite I mean this guy like
like I said this this is another guy
where it just seemed like everything
that he did later seemed like it had
some kind of thing in his childhood that
you could like kind of related back to
him kids are malleable you can do weird
[ __ ] to them when they're young I liked
the hand gesture yeah well you know what
I mean
it's it's in you know people kind of
commonly today even though some other
people are denying it sexuality can be
formed back in the early in early
development but that's just what people
talk about alright
you can go to Africa and see about you
know warrior cults and militias and [ __ ]
like that
you can actually start creating child
soldiers to be very effective murderers
through different techniques like
getting a kid to kill their own parents
at ten you can turn them into a time
bomb like that you know a lot of people
don't know about that but yeah you ever
heard of that
yeah yeah that's but you do is you get a
kid to kill their own parents during a
raid and then afterwards they say you
see you couldn't save your parents you
were weak you were so weak that you
killed your own parents to save yourself
we can make you brave if you stay with
us yeah I mean so that's of course you'd
call it brainwashing brainwashing
involves [ __ ] like that yeah out of it
yeah that's the thing I feel like and I
probably mentioned this a million times
on the show particularly because it will
in regards to serial killers like I said
I think it has to be a combination of
nature and nurture and people have
different degrees of things because some
people have horrific childhoods and turn
out pretty much fine
but I think if you already have
proclivities in that direction and you
have kind of a fucked-up childhood you
don't even need to have as [ __ ] up a
childhood as someone who is more normal
or more mentally strong I guess but you
know if you have like minor things
happen to you and you already have a
predilection like in that direction then
that's gonna mess you up and I think
that was the case with Albert Fish I
mean he obviously his family was just
rife with mental illness he probably was
[ __ ] from the start I'm not you know
empathizing with him I'm not you know
justifying anything that he did I'm just
saying that he was probably born messed
up and then he had this messed up life
that just reinforced it like at every
turn and you know if if he had been
mentally normal and had lived the same
life he might have turned out okay you
know what I'm saying
yeah it's hard for people to kind of
people are the sum of their parts and
you know I mean in their Genesis well
it's hard to tease those two things
apart that's why it's so difficult to
know but like I said it's it's a
continuous combination it's a continuous
feedback loop of you know what you're
like and like bouncing it against the
wall of you know your environment yeah
and you can't get all touchy-feely about
this you know I mean you can't go well
it's not this person's fault fault when
you start when you start talking about
the kind of things that Albert fish and
did fault isn't a factor you find a guy
like Albert fish you kill him
this is what you do I would can't let
him go you can't let him yeah to to kill
him or not someone's my dad ya know it's
like maybe in some other cases it could
be argued but in his case no way no way
because to do that would be doing danger
others yeah and well obviously yeah it
didn't danger dan' I'm with you dealing
with if you want to call him a person
I'm not sure you'd call I'm not sure to
call I don't my sure I could call pal
official person he's one of the very few
people that I don't think person
desiccation personhood involves certain
kinds of mental processes that he didn't
have he was more like a killer robot if
you ask me okay broken machine you know
yeah it's just my my feelings it was
almost not human he was a fake human
that's why I cuz I real human couldn't
do what he did well and another thing
that bothers me too is that he didn't
really have any particular insight know
into why he did what he did he didn't
get it you know with a two-legged lizard
really that hard on that's probably a
good way of putting oh kill a [ __ ] I
have a two-legged lizard with a hard-on
he's coming after me well they did kill
him yeah
spoiler alert well just what he did to
children died I'd smoke his ass yeah
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah to allow
something like that to remain as an
injustice in itself ya know it's my
opinion I agree yeah some people
anti-death-penalty and I just they say
no you guys I'm I'm against it in most
cases just because it seems like it's
not very judiciously applied but there
are some cases where I would not
argue with it and this is definitely one
of those cases so nasty though [ __ ]
he was yeah so okay so he was in an
orphanage for a while like I said you
know he got off on boys getting beaten
he got off on him getting beaten um and
he would often like if he got beaten or
saw other kids getting whipped he would
get an erection and then other the other
kids would tease and yes so all this
other kind of stuff so that was kind of
like a formative experience for him so
now in 1879 his mom actually got like an
okay job and she took them back in she
got them out of the orphanage and was
able to care for them kind of normally
but by this point a lot of the damage
had already been done it seems like so
according to him and according to like a
few other sources like I said he gave
like a big confession like after he got
caught so some of this like I said he
was also kind of a pathological liar so
you could you know take things with a
grain of salt but some things he said
were corroborated yeah that's another
sign of some of it has no
unconsciousness
yeah the liars are always robots if you
ask me well yeah they're just like
randomly spouting out programs you know
so he said that in 80-82 when he was 12
years old that he got involved with his
first in his first homosexual
relationship with the Telegraph boy that
he had met he said that this boy I don't
know if he's ever been named but this
boy was the one that introduced him to
drinking pee and eating [ __ ] yeah so
like you do so twelve-year-old kid he's
like how here have a sip yeah yeah try
that well you know that's all sign of
booking a society that does not have any
kind of publicly developed sexuality
these are people that don't understand
what sexy is you can go back to the
1800s and look at what what what was
considered to be a pornography in the
1800's you look at it it looks like some
kind of clinical effects the crime photo
crime scene photo some girl lifting her
skirt looking at you with a blank stare
and that's what they considered
so I wonder if the blank stare is
considered to be sexier was it just
because I'm sick of holding to suppose
it was a time in which other speed means
mainstream culture had no artistic
expression when it came to sexuality so
you have a bunch of these little feeble
[ __ ] coming up with errors of
the sexuality that might involve
drinking some pee you know I mean that's
some pretty regressive [ __ ] you know I
mean they don't know how to uh they
don't have it they don't know how to
express anything you know talking about
well they don't have any basis and I
feel like they maybe don't know that
like other people might do that too like
I said and I think I've mentioned this
before too it's like that's why I think
it's good now did like people some
people might be freaking out about like
the proliferation of porn and everybody
knows everything about all this I think
that's better I think that's a lot
better because you know if you want to
drink pee with a consenting partner you
do you man it's like it's it's kind of
gross or whatever I'm not gonna get all
on you about it this is all infant ilysm
and sexual regression and yeah it's very
you know and it's like I understand that
some people are into that if you find
somebody else that's into that and you
want to do that together in the privacy
of your own home I am NOT gonna stop you
it doesn't bother me in the leader of
sexual expression you kind of come along
with a well-developed culture these guys
didn't have that they couldn't access
anything to base their desires on I mean
they could didn't have a James Bond
movies with sexy Bond girls you know I
mean it didn't have you know they
couldn't watch new way of hookers part
one order yeah it couldn't watch that
[ __ ] see so they didn't have any didn't
have a slide or my very favorite porno
my ass is haunted
but yes yes that's right the poltergeist
infested ass all right that will never
not be my favorite horror title I've
seen it as well that's that's what's her
name yeah
no no no the real famous one that has
all the sex toys and stuff
Oh bill Donna yeah yeah yeah Bella Donna
was in retired man she he was from
Mississippi
I know yes Jude I went to [ __ ] um
what's that big sex toy store that's
here in Orlando Fair Villa mmm I was at
Fair Villa it was probably like a year
or two ago now and I'm so looking for an
outfit for something and Bella Donna has
a huge huge line if such like half the
[ __ ] sex toys [ __ ] is Bella Donna
[ __ ] yeah she knew what she was doing
man you're branded she's got like molds
of her vagina that you can purchase
she's from Gulfport what is time to be
alive from Gulfport dirty yeah I'm I was
there her dad was in the Navy I was like
Bella she was probably going to the same
clubs I was going to in New Orleans at
the time like the castle in the convent
yeah she's probably going there but
didn't write I don't recognize her I
remember but she would have been there
she always struck me as a super cool
chick seemed like it but I think the
porn industry kana
well that messes a lot of people yeah
it's probably better now than it used to
be but she was living in Mississippi she
went from Mississippi though I think she
was her dad was a Mormon I think she was
from Salt Lake City Lord
raelia kids yeah weird so we're gonna
have to do a show about that yeah
Joseph Smith and all that yeah that was
an interesting thing I studied it okay
all right
so okay so like I said pee drinking poop
eating whatever so he also said that he
would start going around to like public
baths so it'd get like watch the boys
undress and all this other stuff now it
should be noted that even though Albert
Fish um a lot of his victims like some
of his victims he said were boys but he
seemed like an equal-opportunity monster
like he would go after girls as well so
I'm gonna say bisexual and I know a lot
of you know
sources about him say like homosexual
but I feel like he probably was just
like I think it was just whatever it was
an all-you-can-eat buffet yeah
at the [ __ ] up serial killer that's
based on just everything that I know
about
the guy I think what he was he was just
he's just exploited yeah anything that
was around that's what he exploited yeah
anything that was small and weaker than
him because it should be noted that
Albert Fish
not a big dude only 550 530 pounds a
little skinny pursued a little skinny
fella [ __ ]
so you see and I'm I'm you want five six
dudes a [ __ ]
I'd take [ __ ] high I twist fish's
head off don't even you know what don't
even like modern eighty pounds don't
even like give him like don't know sup
don't Sully the word [ __ ] a mother with
Albert Fish yeah these are good
yesterday thats true i could i could
knock fish out just with a [ __ ] hard
stare yeah yeah that's how much the net
worth you're not talking about an into
physical intimidating guy no it was just
little yeah you talk and like i said i'm
in a barrel when he did most of his
iconic crimes he was an old guy like he
looked like a grandpa that's how he got
away with it because everyone said oh
he's just a little bitty old man he's a
little bitty old man yeah kind of like a
[ __ ] alright so when albert fish was
about 24 years old he moved to New York
City now he said that he worked as a
male prostitute for time this has never
been corroborated a [ __ ] was a
bottom welcome power bottom he must have
been yeah he's like dive in dive in now
he also said at around this time that he
had that he had kept like raping little
boys like I said a lot of this stuff has
not been corroborated like there aren't
any crimes that go along with it but so
you know even though he was kind of a
liar I don't see any reason to doubt it
like I said he's a serial killer so they
usually start young I'm gonna getting
into this [ __ ] later okay okay but just
on a side note I wouldn't believe
anything Albert Fish told me there
certainly was a dude like Albert Fish I
wouldn't believe it because the way he
was being a sadomasochistic
lying about
his own suffering is something that
Albert fish would do lying about what a
loser he was was something that Albert
fish would do lying about what a villain
he was was something yes we do so I'd
take a lot of his claims with a grain of
salt but but the thing about it is
though I mean some of the stuff that you
know he said he did he did do that [ __ ]
because they have the bodies they have
like yeah you know one of the girls that
he killed they have like the cut up yeah
boney also I remember he also claimed to
have tortured and killed little children
and those there aren't any tears there
aren't even cases that match right and
he would say well they were it was a
black child well just because the child
was blind assets yeah those kids doesn't
mean that those parents wouldn't report
the child missing there weren't any
missing black children in the area there
was talk that's it yeah that was another
thing that he said that he would do it's
like oh well I I tried to pick like
african-american children or [ __ ]
children yeah you know so that no one
would look for that yeah that sounds
like a lot and I'm like that's kind of
yeah I mean you know yeah they probably
would look for them less maybe but but
their parents would still be looking for
them in the 1920s the 30s and the 40s
african-americans actually on the
average had a very strong family unit
they were doing well you know I mean
they were they had a very low rate of
out of wedlock birth at that time they
were very family oriented you know what
I mean in it if some child goes missing
they make a report I mean nine times out
of a hundred someone's kid goes missing
yeah they're gonna report that good I
don't care what were I don't care what
race era right what economic class they
are it's like it yeah there might be the
one odd one where it's like yeah that
kids left I don't [ __ ] care but it's
like that hardly ever happens that it's
like when it's every human instinct that
there is in in the case of the other
fish in the black children claim I Cal I
kind of called
[ __ ] in general I think he's lying
yeah but that is something that he said
that he would go after ones that were
like mentally impaired or how many
mentally impaired kids are just running
around that's another thing days
probably Hill ha but he did what the
deuce tinnie of them and they never
found any of these bodies yeah they
never found any crimes that were like
yes that was that's the problem with
fish yeah he was a bad dude he's a
murderer don't get me wrong but I also
think he added on top of that [ __ ] a lot
well yeah and like I said we've said
this with a lot of serial killers too
because a lot of serial killers
particularly they're you know of this
particular personality type you know
even though you know provably they've
killed X amount of people but they will
always exaggerate like Henry Lee Lucas I
mean yeah he killed a you know a few
people but did he kill all the people
that he said that he killed actually
doubt it Lucas I'm only convinced that
he killed one yeah three right but then
like any murder that came up that was
unsolved in that air he's like oh yeah I
totally did that [ __ ] yeah cuz he was
just like that and I feel like a lot of
serial killers have that's kind of self
aggrandizing you know it's like they
want to look like this big monster like
yeah I killed a hundred people I killed
200 people what it is that they're
nobodies and they're nonentities and
they have you I honestly have the
attention of law enforcement and in the
media of their day and that's a big deal
to them so they try to do a whole song
and dance and a whole tap dancing
routine to keep them entertained to keep
all eyes on them they love that [ __ ] so
once they give up the crimes that
they've committed they have to start
giving up crimes that they've invented
and sometimes that like four stalls four
stalls just you know just like the death
penalty or trial because they feel like
they have power over people because they
have information even if it's invented
information right that the authorities
don't have it's like oh well they'll
want that [ __ ] so I'm just gonna even if
hint at them that I know I'll but even
the unproven claims of crimes are still
entertaining so we're gonna get into
them too yeah yeah you got to get into
the unproven [ __ ] also all right so
where are we now okay so he's in his 20s
he's in New York City said he's working
as a male prostitute said he'd been
raping
young boys the whole time which he may
well have been sounds like he's flipping
it around sound his booty if you ask me
well it might have been both things like
I said now at this stage his mom
um actually set him up in a marriage now
he married a woman that was nine years
younger than him I think she was 19 when
they married now they eventually ended
up having six children six that's a lot
digits [ __ ] this he was yeah now
the weird thing about him too is that he
he had these six children and according
to them he never laid a hand on although
you know that that kind of checks out a
lot of circo's to have kids love their
kids yeah even my radar Jim Dennis right
well you know I love my children I'm a
good father you know even though a
sexual fry
yeah sexual problems but you know
they're my children yeah I guess if it's
your own sperm yeah yeah they're selfish
you know I mean the kids are you know
they're not gonna do the same they would
you two like stranger not all the time
there's some psycho [ __ ] out
there there's remember that woman that
[ __ ] killed one of her daughters and
tortured all the rest of them and then
yeah left that one out in the damn box
after he shot her and then shot her
years before and then dug the bullet
back out of it well that's another story
I want to do a one on I mean if you guys
have read Jack Ketchum's novel The Girl
Next Door which was based on an actual
real crime it's like the the book is
fictionalized but they he did actually
based on a real crime and they made a
couple movies about it that is some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and that is another
that's another thing it's like you know
yet 90 95 percent of serial killers who
do this [ __ ] up [ __ ] or men but every
now and then get it woman you get a
woman and they do even more messed-up
stuff them yeah they usually do weird
[ __ ] to their children they're on
children yeah that's another thing that
they don't do it to strangers they do do
they know like it's it's very rare when
it happens but it doesn't generally
that's where their poisoners yeah that
too or they are they smother old people
like in death and [ __ ] in the hotel in
the house that's why they don't get
caught see I think I feel like women
serial killers are probably better at it
because they do it in
way that's like unobtrusive so they
might get away so they might get away
with it and people there Casper yes for
the Friendly Ghost
like I said while you're sleeping they
get you mm-hmm yeah never seem calm yeah
easier to not get going yeah all right
so now so Albert he was actually
arrested in 1903 this was the first time
of many arrests many mental hospital
stays things like that he was arrested
for something like pretty minor it was
like embezzlement or petty larceny or
something like that now he went to Sing
Sing he was there for a little while and
had numerous relationships with other
men while he was in prison now when he
got out he started working as a house
painter and he said that he had
continued molesting boys all during this
period most of them under six years old
now he said and I don't know how true
this is again but he said another
formative kind of incident happened when
one of his lovers took him to a wax
museum and while he was in there he's
and this was must been a really weird
wax museum it was the Mutter Museum like
an incentive Pittsburgh I think and
there was a wax thing of like a bisected
penis hmm which you know ok Anatomy
whatever and apparently he was super
super fascinated by that and so after he
saw that he was like hmm and he started
getting like fascinated with the idea of
castration and so he started like
thinking that maybe he would want to
like get a victim and do that to them to
see what it would be like to do that to
somebody so evidently according to him
he gets into a relationship later on
with a mentally challenged man feminism
and he ties him up and tries to castrate
him the guy understandably was like [ __ ]
that noise and broke out and ran away
yeah he ended up biting a piece of it
off though when I remember no I don't
know if he did that bit a piece of it
off weird
quite so weird yeah so after that
apparently after this kind of botched
castration attempt then he starts like
going back and forth so like brothels
and starting to like you know you know
whip me beat me whatever he's been like
I said he's very into you know not only
torturing other people inflicting pain
on other people but he's also super into
inflicting pain on himself he will like
house he has spiked paddles and like
other people let's other people like
spanked him with it until his ass bleeds
it's like he'll weapons like
self-flagellation you know all of that
kind of [ __ ] and there was a whole
religious aspect oh yeah this okay
somehow or another his guilt for what he
was doing and and having a religious
upbringing it kept bringing religion up
to his mind so some sometimes he'd be
like fantasizing about the crucifixion
and then he would be fantasizing about
flagellation it was just self whipping
yourself and atonement yeah so somehow
you worked it out where he thought he
could do whatever he wanted as long as
he was willing to it town for it with
physical pain yeah so he do just weird
[ __ ] to himself you know to try to atone
for what he did and then he would
fantasize about himself being Jesus who
is suffering you know for you know yeah
and then or somebody or John right path
oh yeah or he flip it around think he
was the devil you know it's just weird
he had some problems yeah obviously now
he claims yeah that's doing it got
straighten that out too he's claiming
this it but as weird as this [ __ ] was
that that's probably probably true
there's probably some truth to it I
don't I don't know if its entire percent
true because like I said he had a kind
of a tendency toward fantasy but there I
think there was I think there was some
truth in then you guys go what's she
doing look at it oh my goodness on her
back for this look at her sleeping with
her eyes closed just knocked out on her
back oh my god she is so funny alright
so another like hugely
formative thing and this is according to
him and according to his kids also this
occurred in January of 1917 now his wife
left him for another man who was this
sort of I'm gonna say slow he was a
little slow he was a handyman named John
Straub and he had been living in their
house now this listen to this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] so apparently the wife had
approached Albert fish and said hey can
I move my boyfriend into the house fish
is like no I'd rather not
and then she's like okay fair enough and
then she lets the guy move into the
attic and then she like sneaks food up
to him and [ __ ] like that okay so that
kind of weird [ __ ] was going on yeah now
eventually fish finds out about it so
both of them left so the wife and the
lover took off and left
Albert fish with the six kids now the
youngest of them was three at the time
yeah but now if she was dealing with she
was the primer yeah I mean that kind of
sucks leaving your kids and that's it
you think if it was me I would have
liked taking all the kids and just got
the [ __ ] out like in the middle of it
back in those days you know it's kind of
cold as they were she was like well
that's his seed
yeah maybe they'll all turn out like
yeah right with yeah I mean that's
horrible but you gotta be practical man
but it's women's particularly back that
gee practical man so she's probably like
yeah they'll probably turn out just
[ __ ] up his head so I'm just gonna
like yeah I'm out back today that's what
she did she got out date now the
youngest of their six children was three
at the time as she left so yes so now
fish is I'm gonna say stuck with the six
kids because all six kids later at his
trial when they testified they all said
he was actually a real good dad they
said yeah he did some weird [ __ ] but he
didn't like beat them or he wasn't cruel
to them he was a super-nice for them and
stuff so they compartmentalizing yeah
he's doing yeah now but they did say
that even though he'd been like slightly
weird before hook clearly they said
after the wife left he went woo off the
rails
that's when he started doing like all
the religious stuff like he was wrapping
himself in a carpet and saying I'm Jesus
or I'm John the Apostle or whatever oh
yeah well John the Apostle have hybrid
but yeah so he started having like all
these religious delusions and stuff now
he later told one of his psychiatrist
that was like cuz man he was like a case
study they were lining up to like
interview this too because you're like
what the [ __ ] is the matter with this
guy
he said that whether you believe really
believe this or not I don't know but he
said that he believed that God was
telling him to torture kill and castrate
children and that if God had wanted him
to stop then he would have sent an angel
to stop him just like the Abraham in
Isaac's I remember that yeah yeah so
he's like well since no one came to stop
me then it must be okay I don't believe
that [ __ ] you just want to castrate
people and he was like oh god babe God
well you know if God didn't want to have
me to stop me a lot of people use that
yeah use this is meant to happen
yeah there's no I'm not being struck by
lightning so it must be cool it's
alright now here's the deal that's
messed up did they ever find any
castrated kids oh I don't know not that
I know of
he was just claiming that he did it
mm-hmm see this is the thing the kid
gets cast ruined they're gonna go home
and be like yeah yeah yeah might want to
take me to watch reports of it and then
they're gonna be like who did this they
are we looking for that guy so this
equity be old guy I never could find any
oh you know I'm not an expert in this
case yeah I'm just commenting on what
you're saying I've seen a few shows read
and get about it from other books and
this is a long time ago so you know when
I first read about it I don't really
remember them ever coming forward with
any kids that had been castrated no no
they were eating yeah but castrated you
know I mean so yeah it made me think
thing that a kid would mention yeah I
can't mention that if I didn't get
married cops would get involved they
wouldn't [ __ ] record that and then
later during his trial that would have
been confirmed yeah so I'm not sure he
did that I think he
scared the [ __ ] out of the cops and put
on a song and dance for them maybe you
know like I said unless he just killed
him at the room somewhere I think he was
fantasizing about not he from what I
remember he seemed to have an active
fantasy life yeah from what I remember
he claimed to have castrated kids and
let him go yeah yeah he said he'd done
it yeah he said he'd had at least one in
every state yeah they just strikes me as
[ __ ] yeah because I don't really
think he moves around all that much like
I said he came from DC he mostly lived
in New York City and that was mostly
where he operated even back in those
days you castrate some kid the parents
are gonna hit the [ __ ] roof they're
gonna go to the [ __ ] car yeah that's
something that's and they're gonna be
looking for now yeah and they wouldn't
know about it I just and then when fish
was caught you'd have cops from the
other [ __ ] places going yes yeah that
must have been this guy right here
didn't have him ID it was like it was
now I just I just don't believe it yeah
well like I said they I don't believe a
lot of fantasy and like conflation yeah
even though I mean the [ __ ] he did was
bad enough yeah it's bad enough he just
had to yeah it's putting some icing on
the cake they all they all kind of do
that all right so I feel like we
probably need to yeah we're it's like at
50 minutes so let's take a break right
now it'll be a bad show yeah well when
we come back we will show though I know
it's like I had a comment the other day
that said I always look to see how long
it is and it's like if it's like almost
two hours I get super excited on the
floor still is she really still sleeping
in the good [ __ ]
where is she look at that's it knocked
out oh my god yeah she's so weird yeah
she always she almost always leaves like
that who's on her back she thinks she's
a person I mean when she usually she
sleeps up in her little she had we have
like a huge cat tree you've probably
seen it like in the background sometimes
and she sees she sleeps up in that
little apartment like pretty much all
day like all curled up in there but for
whatever reason whenever she sleeps out
in the house she always just she lays on
her back and weathered a little back
face to get out or belly sticking out
she's like I'm just gonna fall asleep
bright eyes and then she was like
follows
it's so weird she thinks she's a tiny
fuzzy person yeah alright so we're gonna
take a break right now when we come back
we will talk about the crimes that
Albert Fish is probably most famous for
the ones that they actually approved so
we will talk about that in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay that's the biggest quick
beetle I've ever seen planned it
that thing's almost 2 inches long yeah
stop big fake eyes on the back of it
stop it she's pushing there he goes you
don't play dead that things about two
inches long at the big old swamp quick
beetle yeah don't eat him yeah okay the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
Massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts buy
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format
no bright we are back dealing with this
Albert Fish my [ __ ] I can't I can't
believe it
you can't believe it are you on your is
that your second good my second one oh
I'm still only on my first compare this
is a screwdriver actually this is only
my first one dude such a [ __ ] I can't
believe this guy happened yeah I was
kind of thinking that while I was
researching this I'm like how does this
hat like I'm glad it doesn't happen very
often this was like you know lightning
in a bottle but in a bad way I'm just
thankful that this doesn't happen that
often as diesel is alright yeah and and
like I said this is another case where
people are like nowadays like bitching
about
oh [ __ ] so bad nowadays and stuff like
that man for the worse back then oh my
god this dudes like way worse than
anybody I can think of well the law
enforcement techniques weren't good
enough to catch guys like this they and
they didn't really think that things
like this happen so you'd have one of
them and I'm gonna [ __ ] run amok for a
lot longer anyway well yeah because
nobody get crazier like nobody
considered conceived of it yeah and they
just be like who would do something like
that I mean in the way he got caught was
like really now lucky and like really
convoluted if Albert fish were to happen
today in the United States and I don't
think it's possible I would think I
don't think the I don't think he had the
correct environment to create a person
like this anymore probably not but if an
Albert fish were to appear he'd be
caught on his first [ __ ] offense
probably especially like targeting kids
and stuff like that oh ya know and then
if they caught him the first time he'd
just get killed in prison he would have
got caught early on when he was doing a
little [ __ ] yeah I would have identified
him as some kind of weird sexual
offender some kind of nut case that he
kept an eye on him you just can't have a
they didn't have it we have a system
back then like I said it's much better
now I'm just saying I would run around
in the street the 21st century the
United States can't produce guys like
this though nowadays I just don't think
they can well the environment is not the
same like I said it's and we've talked
about this before like
why you don't see the same types of
serial killers II like mass shooters and
stuff like that but you know the type of
stuff that you saw in the early 20th
century you know the early to mid 20th
century you don't really see that
dynamic anymore just because the culture
is different cultures different sad sex
like this would be identified and eaten
early on by other criminals so okay now
let's talk a little bit about they think
actually that his first attack on a
child happened in 1910 and this was in
Wilmington Delaware there's not a lot of
information about this but there was
actually a case that matched up with
this so there is some evidence to
suggest that he had started as early as
1910 when he was about 30 years old
there was also in 1919 there was a
mentally challenged boy who was stabbed
in Georgetown which is part of
Washington DC and that was in 1919 and
there was also a case that corroborated
with that too so that might have been
him as well so again you know earlier
onset of his mania now in 1924 and this
is corroborated by the girl's parents
there was this eight-year-old girl named
Beatrice keel and she was playing on her
her parents had a farm in Staten Island
and she was playing out there and Albert
Fish rolls up to her and says hey I'm
gonna go look for some rhubarb and I
will give you money if you help me look
for it
so she's 8 it's 1924 she's like sure why
not he looks like a harmless dude so she
starts to take off with him and then her
mom comes out and is like no and chases
the old guy away now later Albert fish
comes back to the farm and like tries to
like sleep in their barn but then the
dad comes out and was like no [ __ ] right
off so again there's evidence that
earlier he was starting to do this kind
of [ __ ] so about how old was he around
this time in 1924 he would have been
let's
1970 54 that would have been he would
have been 54 this okay so he's probably
not really cool he hasn't committed his
first homicide yet problem not that they
know of like I said but he's still
clearly nuts working up to it and he's
doing that kind of [ __ ] and you're right
and like I said he might have been
molesting people he might have been
doing all kinds of things up to that
because usually serial killers one
that's not about homicide right and yeah
54 is awful old to start working out -
that's what I'm saying usually this
happens by puberty that's what I'm
saying yeah so I feel like he was
probably doing quote-unquote lesser
crimes earlier molesting kids doing [ __ ]
you know doing [ __ ] like that
probably because it does seem that he
was jailed a few times he was put in
mental hospitals a few times for like
little [ __ ] like he would do like here's
another thing he would do he would find
newspaper ads that women had put in like
looking for maid positions or looking
for husbands or whatever and he would
write to the woman like these filthy
like obscene and he actually got in
trouble for doing that way a few times
like for obscenity in the society
through the [ __ ] mail yeah because he
would do [ __ ] like that somebody wanted
to eat women's peanut butter yeah he
probably didn't even sound somebody I
mean I feel like Dennis would have some
insight into this particular I would
never eat a woman's peanut butter what's
wrong with my peanut butter all right so
now let's talk about the case of the
case which wasn't necessarily the first
homicide he did but this was the one he
got caught for and this is the most
famous one this was the murder of Grace
Budd now this happened in May of 1928 um
okay so grace was only I think she was
like ten years old
now her older brother Edward who was a
tene he had put an ad in the paper like
looking for work and it was in the New
York world and it said something like
young man 18 wishes positioned in
country and he which is weird because
they didn't like specify what he would I
guess he just you know farmhand or
whatever and he puts it in the paper
with his name in his address so a couple
of days later Albert fish shows up at
their house he's 58 years old at this
point
hello man yeah yeah he shows up at their
house in Manhattan and he says that his
name is Frank Howard and that he owns a
farm in Farmingdale New York he's like
super successful and he's looking for
you know big strapping young dudes to
like work on his farm yeah so while he's
there
like he pretty much charms the whole
family he's like super grandfatherly
he's giving all the kids money and candy
and all this other stuff and he says to
Edward bud who was 18 he says oh you
know I totally have work for you it's
like I'll pay you $15 a week he says I
even have work for your best friend
whose name was Willie he's like he can
come too like you guys can work on my
farm I have enough work for both of you
and like it's you know $15 a week that
was like good pay back then this is
1920s so the kids know why I'm like 200
bucks a day yes so like the kids were
super excited yeah um so I think like
pretty much the whole family is kind of
charmed except for the dad he was kind
of like ah he seems kind of weird but I
mean other than that the family were
like dude this is like super exciting
because the you know the kid's gonna get
work and everything so Albert says okay
well I'm gonna I'm gonna hire you the
son and the friend it's like I'll come
back for you in a couple of days and
I'll take you out to the farm and you'll
make $15 a week and everything will be
awesome now over 15 a week or 30 $15 a
week okay yeah yeah looks like this was
1928 I mean that was a lot of money I I
did it I didn't do the Google like the
the currency converter or whatever I got
however that lost different things back
then 15 bucks a week
could have been probably more kind of
like harder $50 a week something like
that maybe which is you know that's
pretty good good that's less than Batman
these were cheap and good and yeah back
then you made less and you could get a
loaf of bread for like a nickel yes it
was probably like the equivalent of like
$30 a week yeah it's you made 200 it had
been a good wage for a poor person back
then that's what I should have looked it
up before I started the show it's what I
should have done because there's a
there's a thing on Google where you can
like say how much is this amount like
how much spending power would you do
yeah yeah during that era spending power
was very very different that's some
badass handcrafted pistols like little
Colt 32 pocket hammerless pistols today
you know to make that pistol like that'd
be like seven eight hundred bucks
because there's hand fitting involved
yeah but back in those days you could
get one maybe twenty twenty-five dollars
but twenty-five dollars was a lot of
money back well yeah that was a lot of
money so yeah it all kind of worked out
in a weird way I mean for some people
that would have been like a month yes
salary like a week like maybe maybe I
don't know 25 bucks maybe
but yeah so he okay so he says I'm gonna
come back for him and he did actually he
said he was gonna come back on this one
particular day but he didn't but he did
send it like a telegram I said oh I'm
sorry I got delayed I'll come tomorrow
instead you know he did actually come
back on the second time and when he came
back the second time he brought with him
what they would I don't know why that
keeps silly but every source that I say
is he's pot cheese what the [ __ ] is that
wait a min hold on wait what hot cheese
pot cheese is parties in a pot no
probably they're talking about his head
cheese jeez well yeah that's what I was
thinking I wasn't sure if any people
don't know what head cheese is did you
see you access Chainsaw Massacre you
know what head cheese is yeah like some
nasty [ __ ] head cheese is [ __ ]
fantastic it's kind of like really
countrified baloney or sausage but it's
better it comes in like a loaf it's got
like gelatin holding a bunch of meat
together yeah it was me Michael stop of
a bone and it's season pretty [ __ ]
well alright
Cajun head cheese I loved it that's what
that Cajun spice
you also eat chicken hearts I love
chicken hearts I'll eat a thousand
chicken hearts in that area last check I
love chicken Archie that's why I brought
it out you like bacon
yeah but yeah that's probably they're
talking about some I had cheese it might
have been yeah I'm just like I said ever
every source says I just said pot cheese
so Jesus so he comes back it's the
things that cooks off all the bones and
it falls to the bottom then you and they
make like you take all those little yeah
it's not cheese it's not Jesus meatloaf
yeah it's like a cold meatloaf you eat
and it's yeah it's it's like a hot dog
but not really more like a Bologna
yeah okay you psyche to the gelatin from
hooves
that's where gelatin comes from yeah and
you hold it all together and you make
like a meatloaf with it you season it
with like nice seasoning and salt you
slice it get slices off of that meatloaf
and you put it on bread yeah make a
sandwich out of it Mike
yeah like I said like a really fancy
it's kind of like in the UK how they how
they would eat blood sausage ways head
cheese is usually about a foot long and
six inches by six inches so the both
sides of a piece of bread like a loaf of
bread and you slice it yeah it's yeah
I've seen [ __ ] like I said you put my
grip my granddad used to yeah yeah like
I said that just reminded me of when I
was in the UK and people thought jeez
what breakfast and I was just kind of
like crazy this was like older piece
funny we're arguing over the food you
know yeah well it was one thing that I
came across I'm like pot cheese Watchi
is that is that cheese or is it like not
cheese
no it's it's like it's baloney slash
meatloaf type so he comes to the house
the second time and he has the
quote-unquote pot cheese he also has
like a bunch of strawberries and he got
and he gives the kids more money gives
them money for candies like here have
some money go to the movies like Joseph
and like everyone was like oh
what a nice man he is now he says I'm
gonna come back and you know pick up the
boys and I'm gonna take them to the farm
to work but in the meantime he sees the
10 year old Grace who by all and I've
seen photographs of her and by all
accounts she was a very beautiful child
she comes into the room she still has
her little white dress on from church
and he is all about that so he says to
the parents he's like hey you know my
sister is having a little birthday party
would you mind if I took grace to this
birthday party and she can meet all
these other kids and all this other kind
of stuff now her parents
this was the 1920s you guys you have to
understand this was a more naive time I
suppose now I do feel like maybe the
parents were just kind of like I don't
know but he seemed like such a nice man
he was like an older man and stuff
they're like yeah okay and he gave them
the address it's like this is my
sister's house she lives on this street
or whatever and it's like I'm just gonna
take her to the party you'll be super
fun so they let her go with him well she
was like he was an old grandfather they
come that's it yeah they figured there
was no risk right but this is a [ __ ]
walking lizard with a [ __ ] hard-on
and he was [ __ ] crazy yeah took this
girl to an abandoned house killed her
Eider yeah yeah and then wrote to the
parents good you can go ahead and talk
about yeah but if you ask me if he asked
me I think this was his first homicide
know that well there were a couple I
think that happened before this but they
didn't find out until after he got
caught after he got caught okay okay
then I stand correct I mean this is the
one is the one that's really made famous
right yes and I don't think I just I
just and you'll know why when I read the
letter yeah and I just thing is this is
I just don't think this guy's are a
highly produced killer I think it's a
sexual predator really yeah I think he
killed some but not as many as he
claimed yeah but you can get into it go
ahead so alright so he takes the kid
away and um you know the parents are
like I was fine she
going to a party or whatever now
obviously because this is Albert finish
we know that grace bud never came back
yeah now the next day like as the night
went on the parents weren't initially
all that alarmed because they thought
well maybe the party just ran late and
she decided to sleep over at the guy's
sister's house and it's fine but then
the next day the dad was like alright
[ __ ] this I'm gonna go check out this
address and I'm gonna go to the address
that he gave us yeah and that he found
out that that address did not exist it
exists yeah so he went to the police and
reported her missing yeah
now a couple of other people before the
body was found or before they knew what
happened to the little girl a couple
other people were arrested for the crime
like a guy named Charles Edward Pope was
arrested in September of 1930 and he was
a suspect he was also an old guy
everything he was 66 but they they
actually I think he had been in jail but
they figured out that he didn't do it
then there was another guy that they
thought did it too
now so they this case went unsolved for
quite a long time it was like six or
seven years then in 1934 actually late
1934 an anonymous letter is sent to the
girl's parents the buds now should I
read the whole letter glad read it yeah
pretty yeah this is what the letter said
dear mrs. bud in 1894 a friend of mine
shipped as a deckhand on the steamer to
come up Captain John Davis they sailed
from San Francisco for Hong Kong China
on arriving there he and two others went
ashore and got drunk like you do that's
me that's not in the letter when they
returned the boat was gone at that time
there was a famine in China meat of any
kind was from 1 to $3 per pound so great
was the suffering among the very poor
that all children under 12 were sold for
food in order to keep others from
starving I called [ __ ] that's that
never had a boy or girl under 14 was not
safe in the street you could go in any
shop and ask for steak chops or stew
meat part of the naked body of a boy or
girl would
brought out and just what you wanted cut
from it like I said this is fantasy [ __ ]
right here nobody it's like yeah I'm not
saying that people don't Resorts can
there was they were selling buddy a boy
or girls behind which is the sweetest
part of the body yeah as we all know and
soul does veal cutlet brought the
highest praise John stayed there so long
he acquired a taste for human flesh on
its return in New York he stole two boys
one seven and one eleven took them to
his home stripped them naked tied them
in a closet then burned everything they
had on several times every day and night
he spanked them tortured them to make
their meat good and tender first he
killed the 11-year old boy
because he had the fattest ass and of
course the most meat on it
every part of his body was cooked and
eaten except the head bones and guts
he was roasted in the oven all of his
ass boiled broiled fried and stewed all
of his ass all of his all of us is not
just part of it yeah right
which was prior to way what two or three
pounds on a boy the little boy was next
went the same way at that time I was
living at 409 East 100th Street near
right side he told me so often how good
human flesh was I made up my mind to
taste it on Sunday June the 3rd 1928 I
called on you at 406 West 15th Street
brought you pot cheese and strawberries
we had lunch
grace sat in my lap and kissed me I made
up my mind to eat her on the pretense of
taking her to a party you said yes she
could go I took her to an empty house in
Westchester
I had already picked out when we got
there I told the shore mate outside she
picked wildflower wildflowers I went
upstairs and stripped all my clothes off
I knew if I did not I would get her
blood on them when all was ready I went
to the window and called her then I hid
in a closet until she was in the room
when she saw me all naked she began to
cry as you would and tried to run down
the stairs
I grabbed her and said she would tell
her mama I grabbed her and she said she
would tell her mama first I stripped her
naked how she
kick bite and scratch I choked her to
death then cut her in small pieces so I
could take my meat to my rooms cook and
eat it how sweet and tender her little
ass was roasted in the oven it took me
nine days to eat her entire body I did
not [ __ ] her though I could have and I
wished could of he said I could I hate
that she died a virgin
alright that was the letter that he sent
to the bud family now the mom Grace's
mom couldn't read she was illiterate so
she had to have somebody read that to
her son had to read this [ __ ] letter
to the mother about what had happened
and this is like I said this is six or
seven years after the little girl
disappeared and they didn't know what
happened to her so they read that to the
kid now later on apparently Albert fish
said yeah I did rape her I figured yeah
like I said I don't know how I think he
raped an aider well he did he for sure
did yeah they found her bones later on
so you find the bones um he had had like
the the house that he had yeah there was
like a like a stone wall like behind it
and he had thrown like a bunch of bones
over it and also like the saw and the
cleaver and stuff that he had used to
cut her up it was all over there yeah
well they were cut up okay yeah because
you can tell if about has been cooked or
not I don't know if I don't know if he
cut the meat off the bone and then
cooked it I don't know yeah but um yeah
I think part of that story's true all
this [ __ ] about China well no that's all
the thing about it is that he said oh I
I have a friend not me yessum that was
like that was in China and they got a
developed it I think that was like some
fantasy [ __ ] there yeah but he was like
trying to justify what the later part
like at a later part that was what he
really did but he was trying to say oh
well someone else did it first and gave
me the idea so it almost like mitigated
it someone really a little girl yeah I
feel like that's what he was trying to
do cuz he was like oh it's not just me
it's like some other dude that did it
and he was the one that gave me the idea
so I'm not completely culpable maybe
that's what he was trying to do I'm not
really sure that's [ __ ] yeah yeah so
um later on when they after they caught
him and they said that yeah what do you
did
what he did was he's like yeah he's
gonna take this little girl to this
party quote-unquote and he said he buys
a train ticket for himself he buys a
one-way ticket for her and then they get
on the train and they go it's like a 40
minute ride or something and the little
girl was excited that she was gonna
party she never gets to go anywhere and
stuff yeah and then he gets off the
train to transfer and he had like this
little like a bundle that had all his
what he called implements of Hell in it
it was like a saw and like a [ __ ]
cleaver and some other [ __ ] and he
actually left it on the train because he
was so excited and the little girl went
back and got it she's like hey you
forgot this and then like brought it to
him and loved like they transfer the
train it's like oh my god that's
horrible for some reason that like
detail really bothered me so um yeah so
like I said later on they did find her
like bones behind this wall where he
said he had thrown them yeah now
interesting so now interestingly like I
said this they didn't know who had done
it like all this time now the letter
when it arrived they noticed like I
think they were looking at it under like
a microscope or they were looking at
really closely and there was this little
logo on it or they saw that like I think
fish had like trying to scratch it out
so like this little logo on it that said
NY PCB a and they and and they like
researched it and they found out that
that stood for New York private
chauffeurs benevolent associations
they're like that's where the stationery
had come from so they go to this place
and they're like asking all the people
it's like do you know like who could
have sent this somebody here sent this
or somebody using this stationery now
they did handwriting tests on all the
people from this particular club and
none of the handwriting matched that of
the letter however a janitor who worked
at the club came forward and said you
know I took a bunch of that stationery
home with me and used it and he had
taken the stationery to this boarding
house where he had been staying and it
just so happened that the room the rehab
been staying and he had left some of the
stationery there and when they went to
that boarding house it was kind of like
this yucky flophouse that was where
Albert Fischer was saying yeah that's
how they [ __ ] caught him this little
[ __ ] logo that was on the stationery
that he had tried to scratch out so he
wasn't that stupid so they so that's how
they he ended up getting caught because
he they went to the boarding house and
they asked the landlady they said you
know who's staying in this room which is
like I was this a nice old man and he
but he hasn't been around for a day or
two and they thought that he had left
but then the cop rented a room in that
flop house and then he waited and then
it was like three days or something like
that and then Albert Fish came back or
like a few days later it's like yeah
he's just waiting and yeah and then like
he came back now I'd make a good movie
you know this movie I wonder if any but
I'm sure somebody has has somebody
somebody's made him our fish maybe
surely I've seen Elvis documentaries
well yeah so by but I don't know if yeah
I don't know so the cop comes into the
boarding house and he's like hey Albert
Fish I'm arresting you and Albert fish
at first like seems like he's
cooperating like yeah I'll totally go
with you down to the station answer some
questions or whatever and then he goes
well Shaw and then he pulls like razors
out of his [ __ ] pocket like [ __ ]
great straight razors and Legos like
eternity time right and he tries to like
kill the cat and the cops are like ya
know cut that yeah and they just they
just arrested him
now one day later found out was that
like he apparently like made no secret
about that he was the one that killed
gray spud now he said that what my
initial plan was was but when I saw the
ad that Edward Budd had placed
who was 18 years old in the newspaper I
was gonna go there I was gonna kidnap
him and I was gonna restrain him and cut
his penis off and then watch him bleed
to death but then when he got to the
house and he saw Grace who was 10 he
either liked her better and likes the
idea of eating her better or he or and
or
thought that Edward Budd would be too
large a person for him to restrain
because everybody was a big strapping 18
year old kid okay
so right there what is that so yeah
there might have been some aspect of
that it's like oh I don't think I could
deal with that cuz like I said Albert
fish was just like a little bitty dude
you see he you know he was only 130
pounds but maybe 5.5 hundred thirty
pounds
that's one me a little yeah he's a
little skinny dude so okay so after they
caught him uh they discovered that he
had been responsible for at least two
other murders and he's suspected in like
three other ones now the first of these
was a kid named Billy Gaffney now this
happened in February of 1927
now Billy Gaffney he had another friend
who was also named Billy but Billy
beaten they were playing outside of
their apartment in Brooklyn now both of
the kids like disappeared but then Billy
Beaton was found later on on the roof of
the apartment building now he got asked
like what happened to your friend Billy
Gaffney and this kid said the boogey man
took him quote-unquote yeah now there
were a couple suspects for this but
later on after they caught Albert fish
he said yeah I did that [ __ ] booty man
yeah and also there was some
corroborating evidence because there was
a guy named Joseph Meehan who worked on
the Brooklyn trolley and after he saw a
picture of Albert fish in the paper like
for the Grace Budd murder he's like
that's the guy that I saw in February of
1927 he was on a trolley with a little
boy he dragged him onto the trolley and
the kid was crying and like asking for
his mother and he didn't have a coat on
and it was really cold outside and he
thought it was like suspicious so he so
he identified Albert fish as you so
that's two now they never did find Billy
Gaffney's body but they're pretty sure
that he did that she's always reported
missing
yes so we know that that's and yet he
was reported missing and like I said
someone else saw him in
you know the company of Albert fish or
someone who looked like ever fish now
later on after Albert fish was
imprisoned Billy Gaffney's mother went
to ask him about it and Albert fish said
the following this is what he said about
Billy Gaffney's murder and take this
with a grain of salt
I don't know what he said well like I
said they never found this kid and he's
still missing so I'm presuming that this
is probably fairly accurate usually what
happens at a time like this is that the
the offender tells a story that will
cause the [ __ ] parents to suffer the
most that's usually with it that could
be but it could be that he actually did
the shakes like I said they never found
the kid this is what he said I brought
him to the Riker Avenue dumps there is a
house that stands alone not far from
where I took him I took the boy there
stripped him naked and tied his hands
and feet and gagged him with a piece of
dirty rag I picked out at the dump
then I burned his clothes threw his
shoes in the dump then I walked back and
took the trolley to 59th Street at 2
a.m. and walked from their home next day
about 2 p.m.
I took tools a good heavy
cat-o'-nine-tails
homemade short handle cut one of my
belts in half
slit these halves in six strips about
eight inches long I whipped his bare
behind till the blood ran from his legs
I cut off his ears nose slit his mouth
from ear to ear
gouge out his eyes he was dead then I
stuck the knife in his belly and held my
mouth to his body and drank his blood I
picked up four old potato sacks and
gathered a pile of stones then I cut him
up I had a grip with me I had to look up
grip it's actually just a traveling bag
I put his nose ears and a few slices of
his belly in the grip then I cut him
through the middle of his body just
below the belly button
then through his legs about two inches
below his behind I put this in my grip
with a lot of paper I cut off the head
feet arms hands and legs below the knee
this I put in sacks weighed with stones
tied the ends and threw them into the
pools of slimy water you will see all
along the road go into North Beach I
came home with my meat I had the front
of his body I liked best his monkey and
pee-wee's which I guess is his dick and
balls right yeah and a nice little fat
behind to roast in the oven and eat
I made a stew out of his ears nose
pieces of his face and belly I put
onions carrots turnips celery salt and
pepper
it was good then I split the cheeks of
his behind open cut off his monkey and
pee-wee's and washed them first
I put strips of bacon on each cheek of
his behind hey it's like you putting
bacon on everything what and put them in
the oven then I picked four onions and
when the meat had roasted about a
quarter of an hour I poured about a pint
of water over it for gravy and put in
the onions at frequent intervals i
basted his behind with a wooden spoon so
the meat would be nice and juicy in
about two hours it was nice and brown
cooked through I never ate any roast
turkey that tasted half as good as his
sweet fat little behind it I ate every
bit of the meat in about four days his
little monkey was as sweet as a nut but
his pee wees I could not chew and I
threw them in the toilet that's what he
said he did too this little kid did he
do this probably I think you only had I
think you did about half of that he's
embellishing maybe like I said he had a
very active fantasy life so it's hard to
tell but they're pretty sure that he did
eat grace bud and I really did have two
hours he overcooked it maybe he likes it
like that cannibalism
yeah well he did kill the boy yeah that
was the second one right that was number
two right yeah now there was another one
to you but I'll get to that a minute
good now they actually put Albert fish
on trial for just grace buds murder he
was put on trial in 1935 in a White
Plains New York
now the he actually at first pleaded
insanity
um and said the whole thing about God
told me to kill children and castrate
them and whatnot there were a bunch of
psychiatrist that like you know had
conversation with them they were trying
to like determine whether he was
competent to stand trial or not
that's kind of the thing it's like even
though a lot of psychiatrists like talk
to him or like yeah he's [ __ ] crazy
but a lot of them said that he was seen
enough to stand trial so he did actually
stand trial for murder but he was kind
of like as I said before the
psychiatrist like line it up to talk to
this dude because this dude was like
super [ __ ] up they have this one
witness that was named Frederick wertham
who talked to him like quite extensively
and he said that he thought that that
fish was insane Oh [ __ ] crazy
yes there was another thing too and I
thought you might find this very
interesting I saw this mention to one of
my sources was that his defense attorney
actually thought that they could get
away with maybe saying that he had what
they called back in the day lead colic
they said that was something like a form
of dementia right that was suffered by
house painters because of all the lead
in the paint so that was something that
like they knew about back in the day
it's not normal psychology you mean the
[ __ ] and abuse do with all kinds of
weird fetishes and you know and then he
starts getting into pedophilia and
killing people and [ __ ] weird [ __ ] like
that it was not normal
they usually not you know clearly and he
came from a family where they had
schizophrenia and it does kind of among
up many other men right and and he's old
when he's doing this yeah so you're not
dealing with a 15 year old boy going
through puberty and he's a young serial
killer up and coming he's an old man
yeah we're like you know it's mental
illness like I don't out he's going
after little kids I'm not sure this guy
would have come out normal whatever
because it seemed like he was just
[ __ ] from this you know what 5858 we
did in some of the ground you know yeah
I kind of [ __ ] six Drive we talking
about a 58 year old man really shouldn't
really give a [ __ ] this [ __ ]
crazy yeah yeah like I said this is this
is why right we still know this dudes
right and he's thought to be partially
the inspiration for Hannibal Lecter is
the cannibalism good stuff
although weight gain is also kind of
thrown around us that too we have to do
a show there Isaac oh yeah so at the
trial they actually all of his kids
testified now most of his kids testified
he had never beaten them he'd been a
good father and stuff but they said that
he would do weird [ __ ] like they said
well he had this thing that he called
the game what he would do is he would
like take off his clothes and he would
like get on all fours and then he would
have like he would hold up fingers like
however many times like you had a guess
how many fingers he was holding up or
something and like if the kids guessed
right or wrong or whatever then they
would have to beat him that number of
times either with like a paint stick
like a you know stick the store paint
weather or with a hairbrush so he didn't
like beat the kids but he got the kids
to beat him beat him because he was into
that yet so that was that whole thing -
also they said that he would stick pins
under his fingernails like while they
were watching him like he kind of got
into that oh yeah we can get that later
because this dude tortured himself with
[ __ ] needles needles deep into his
own body they were in there when they
executed well yes see that's another
thing and I was just gonna mention that
just now like a lot of sites
psychiatrist said that well they thought
he was bullshitting when he said this
because they said well what he what he
would like to do was he would take
needles and pins and he would stick them
essentially into his taint like it was
all around like his scrotum and like
between his scrotum in his anus and at
first he was like sticking in them in
there and then pulling them back out but
after a while he's like you know what
I'm just sticking it I'm just gonna
leave it in there maybe migrate up into
his body and so like he would start
leaving them in there and like I said
the psychiatrist thought he was
bullshitting and then they x-rayed him
and they found 29 rusty needles all up
in his [ __ ] pelvic area yeah he would
just go like yeah I put him there never
saw him again
yeah where'd they go who knows Dictator
was excruciating you know
stick needles up in your taint you lose
track of that yes so yeah that's this is
my health unfair yeah yeah that's just
that's just that's just additional
evidence I'm saying the [ __ ] was
crazy
clearly [ __ ] I say he's very obviously I
do not I don't think he was a what you
would call it a normal serial killer you
know yeah almost sir could you talk
about some of the has its kind of
sometimes schizophrenia some kind of
[ __ ] like he said the lead poisoning
this was it this was a combination of
several it was a combination of a bunch
of stuff I think he was messed up when
he was born because it was so much
mental and a bunch of family and then
like he had a bunch of abuse at the
orphanage and then maybe lead paint it
was a perfect storm another thing is is
that some of this abuse that he went
through maybe he wouldn't have had to
have gone through that abuse had he been
of right sound mind also to begin with
because a reasonable [ __ ] can
avoid that kind of [ __ ] that's what I
mean like you know something comes to me
with something sideways I'm knock your
ass out I mean okay
thousands army I mean maybe even
millions of children sadly you know are
abused or under its you know emotional
abuse physical abuse whatever and most
of them turn out pretty much okay it was
like in the sense that they're not going
to go out and hurt other people and then
there's like all the attempts people try
to molest the kid the kid is the right
response and the [ __ ] perverse okay
yeah you know that happens but yeah so
alright so he basically you know even
though his defense returned Allah always
insane he is led poison blah blah blah
but I think the jury only delivered like
an hour in this like ya know let's let's
fries us and you know rightly so now
after the sentencing he actually
confessed to another murder and this was
a kid named Francis McDonald who was
eight years old now this happened in
1924 on Staten Island apparently Francis
was playing on the front porch of his
house and Francis's mother actually saw
this old guy walk
and she was weirded out by him cuz he
was walking by like kind of mumbling to
himself and like clenching and
unclenching his fists and she thought it
was really weird and she he just went by
and he didn't say anything and then
later on that afternoon she saw the guy
again and he was just like standing
there like watching Francis and his like
friends playing in the yard and then
Francis later that day disappeared and
then later on they found him in the
woods like they found his body and they
found it in the woods like near where he
had been playing in near where the old
man had been seen so he had actually
been sexually assaulted and he'd
actually been strangled with his little
suspenders so that was another one so so
like I said you know canonically like I
said he's known for three murders but
they think he probably killed more than
that they just can't prove it so I'm
gonna say they're seeing three that they
can prove well and there are three other
that they three others that they think
you might have done because he was in
the area and the motive six is
reasonable but from what I remember they
do is lying yeah like he was saying I
don't think he said he killed more than
a hundred but he did say that he had
molested or and or tortured more than a
hundred some of these tortures he was
talking about were so Grievous though
that they would have been reported they
just couldn't have been I'm not saying
that he didn't molest a bunch of kids
cuz he probably did you could do that
back in those days but back in those
days that might not have been a report
because the kid might have been scared
or the kid might not have said anything
or the parents might even like whatever
you [ __ ] about cut off his peewee and
his monkey is it no that [ __ ] would have
been reported yeah kid couldn't hide
that ya know they just couldn't
yeah all [ __ ] on a lot of the [ __ ]
that he said I think he killed probably
bout six seven people probably molested
none twenty thirty people so yeah a
couple of the psychiatrists that talked
to him were saying that his victim like
murders were probably about 15 but it's
possible he could have molested like
a lot more than that but murders they're
saying maybe 15 were they 10 to 15 where
they get well just from talking to him
and the you know the details that he
gave of our particular crimes they're
thinking it's somewhere in the range of
10 to 15 but you know they're not
certain molesting they're like it's
probably a lot more than I went ahead
and said maybe 7 and 10 is not that far
from set yeah you know they're saying
between 10 and 15 I'm gonna say probably
more like about 7 6 7 8 9 10 around that
so okay so he was actually executed in
March of 1935 or he actually got to the
prison in March at night to their
phobias it executed in January to 36
it's in sync Singh
now very famously when they told him he
was getting the chair yeah he seemed
super excited about it yeah he's a
[ __ ] massacre well he yeah he was
kind of like oh this is a thrill that
I've never had well ride the line and he
was like yeah and he was seemed like
kind of excited about what it was gonna
feel like now delish
yeah he called it what else did he Harry
what the supreme thrill of my life what
else did he had to live for he was
experimenting perverted old man carrying
around a bunch of guilt for the [ __ ]
crimes he had committed he loved to be
punished for the [ __ ] [ __ ] that he
had done you know I mean even before he
got caught he was [ __ ] punishing
himself to try to a'tall yeah oh yeah
that [ __ ] wanted to die yeah he
wasn't yeah yeah now the legend goes
that it took longer to electrocute him
because of all the pin cities like
needles that he's stuck in his body like
all the red that is actually an urban
legend though that is actually not the
case he was electrocuted just like
everyone else bolted you can't but yeah
but that's a legend that was good
because he had so much metal that he'd
stuck up his ass yeah that it would like
somehow Georgia shaved off the electric
chair voltage I don't even know that's I
don't know electricity work people would
come up with these urban legends all
right so even though he said he
done a lot more murders they suspect him
in three more and they suspect that he
might have been this unknown figure
called the Brooklyn vampire who kind of
he was a rapist and murderer mostly when
I never went after children now there
was a girl there in 1927 named Vienna
Abramowitz and this happened in the
Bronx she was 12 years old she was
actually strangled and beaten to death
on the roof of a five-story apartment
house and died in a hospital after she
was found now they suspect that maybe
fish did this one as well of the modus
operandi was very similar the area was
very similar he was in the area at the
time there was also one in 1932 a 16
year old girl named Mary Ellen O'Connor
this was in Far Rockaway in Queens and
she was found in the woods she was she
had been mutilated and she would the
place where she was found was very close
to a house that fish had been painting
at the time that she was murdered but
here's the thing that he confessed to
this um he did not but some things that
he said led them to believe that he knew
something about them the way he was
though he would have probably confessed
and glorified every one of his second
homicides maybe but I don't know he
seemed like it would seem like that in
in any other case I would probably agree
with you but I'm not sure because he was
so so crazy did he maybe forgot it's
possible it in some ways I feel like
that maybe he did so much bad [ __ ] that
he couldn't even remember it you know
what I mean
because I find it very I mean just from
what I know about how serial killers
operate it seems very very unlikely that
he waited until he was in his fifties
before he started killing people I think
he killed some people
I don't want an almost serial killer
well he's definitely not for sure he's
an anomaly anyway he started too late
to be a yes sir it just seems very
strange sounds like mental illness slash
maybe lead poisoning like yeah you know
he was painting a lot this year that oh
yeah that was
there was a house there that'll make you
[ __ ] crazy as a hatter cuz [ __ ]
that's what a that's why Hatter's were
[ __ ] mad
all that damn led yeah you know that
we're using all the dyes and the paint
stuff back then that's what happened is
just like all the [ __ ] they put in your
[ __ ] wallpaper and your clothes stuff
with me makes you wonder what they're
doing to us today I wouldn't worry about
it because like I said it can't be as
best for all we know all this [ __ ]
wireless internet might be [ __ ] up
our brains hey you don't think so
remember back in the day they were
worried about for the radio signals I
cannot beat my brains alright I mean as
far as I know my brain would okay so
there was also another one in 1932 a 17
year old boy named Benjamin Collings and
they think that he might have done that
one as well
now interestingly as I said before you
know they did extensive interviews with
him several psychiatrists interviewed
him and as I said he didn't really seem
to have any particular insight into what
into why he did what he did he said like
before they executed him he said and I
quote I have no particular desire to
live I had a particular desire to be
killed it is a matter of indifference to
me yeah I do not think I am altogether
right yeah you think lead poisoning and
reading Nietzsche he said I never could
understand myself yeah but yeah like so
other [ __ ] he did that I don't think I
even mentioned that he admitted later on
he would take like pieces of cotton or
wool or something like so command
alcohols I remember this but yes and set
them on fire kind of like lighting farts
but yeah more extreme inside himself
yeah that's right
and then like I said about the needles
and stuff and the web studded paddles
why not work the inside his colon looked
like I have an x-ray abut you I have an
x-ray it's all black and brown have the
x-ray of his pelvis yeah I'm pretty sure
I found it on the Internet there's an
x-ray of his pelvis that shows like all
the needles did he stuck up in there
because so there were three - or three
the three
sure and three more suspected suspected
but like I said the psychiatrist thought
that it was probably more than that but
not like a hundred they thought it was
maybe ten to fifteen because there were
a lot of you know missing kids murdered
kids there were some unsolved murders
that could have been him they like in
the area because it was similar to what
he would do I know what I'm gonna say
notice it there are there were guys like
that though other ones are running
around that's that's that you're
justjust just on the [ __ ] description
of how he was what this what it was like
back then
I bet using like four or five people
that he killed and the rest of that's
enough they're like okay oh yeah yeah
it's a lot understand I think he I think
he embellished the rest of it well I'm
like I said it wasn't just murders I
feel like he probably like oh yeah I
think he molested him when he was young
yeah that's how I think it started out
as he got and then that doesn't get
reported as much especially back then
yes he got worse when he got older he
killed a few of them
that's it probably what happened and ate
them and ate him we dealing to do all
kinds of [ __ ] weird-ass dark fetishes
because of all this [ __ ] out you know
lead poisoning and bad breeding and
horrible [ __ ] going on back then and all
this weird genetic profile from all
those [ __ ] crazy-ass ancestors that
gave you know rise to this he was a
piece of [ __ ] like if you'd like to go
around saying oh his ancestors were like
have fought in the American Revolution
which they very well may have look and
you know I'm but that doesn't mean that
you're not messed up I'm not a size
issed you know what I mean [ __ ]
by the size I'm a smaller kind of guy
you know I mean but you know I have some
weight on me but a 5 foot 5 guy with 130
pounds I don't think he had the physical
prowess well [ __ ] I could knock your ass
to go up yeah dude like that but I don't
think he had the physical prowess to go
out and hunt down even children for for
that period of time would not be
captured by adults yeah that's what I'm
saying
yeah you're gonna get long if he's gonna
like moleska I think I feel like he
probably targeted younger ones because
he did say that he raped young boys
molesting boys and we're always under
six but which that to me seems sounds
like to go along with did it match up
with the complaints he a guy would but I
mean if it was just if it wasn't
murderers if it was just molesting this
is like late 18-hundreds early night
thank you would anybody really report
that the thing I remember some of those
things that [ __ ] said is that he
got little black boys and tortured them
to death yeah and that would have been
reported well yeah like any kid would
anything of that extent yeah he was
[ __ ] lyin if he asked me he was trying
to say well you know maybe these guys
don't care about the black kids and I do
that and then then but like I said I
feel like he did a lot of bad [ __ ] but
he just like made it worse than it the
whole you know he just embellished it
the whole thing maybe he didn't kill
kids maybe he's just molested the whole
thing about going after little black
kids and Albert Fish is [ __ ] think
it's very similar to Billy the Kid talk
about how many Mexicans he killed yeah
cuz you couldn't prove how many Mexicans
if I can Billy the Kid killed I I got
kill these people but [ __ ] how much I
can't claim it's white people because
there'd be records they're gonna count
them dinner cow no nobody counts nobody
else was there
that's that's what he's doing
yeah I feel like that but like I said I
do feel like that he probably did like
molest some kids but not to the extent
that I mean if the kids were young
enough and maybe if he preyed on ones
that were you know what I mean it will
less than average kids and average black
kids and cutting off what do you call
them they're monkeys and they're
pee-wee's that would have been reported
yeah it's know when a little kid comes
back he's going well yeah if your son
comes back it doesn't have a pickup
anymore that's a red flag right let's be
honest be honest the parents would freak
the [ __ ] out yeah they would go to the
cops and the cops would be like got a
[ __ ] running around cutting off
monkeys and pee-wee's he's [ __ ] yeah
no prob about four or five P
but like I said that's bad enough yeah
and I'm sure he did horrible [ __ ] that
you know but he just like embellished
Italy that's might be and and I feel
like ate the monkey but the pee-wee's
were too [ __ ] hard so I just wit
amount yeah yeah right like he like like
like like he's a kind of sore yeah
these are too tough everybody knows the
answer yeah yeah yeah
bacon Thank You bacon on top of it and
I'm thinking a little kids I ask yeah
I'm a cook too you know every little
kids ass probably won't weigh about
pound per pound me just super practical
yeah and you're gonna cook that [ __ ]
for two hours what temperature you cook
it at cook he said it was huge he's
talking about like he's talking about
was it for the turn name of a [ __ ]
big ass porn star trying to talk about
you know we're not talking about a 15
pound two hours well I was thinking of
like maybe like a little like a pork
roast earlier was named spicy J I think
your name is spicy J she lives here in
Florida one of the big in has all the
points well don't Google it she lives
down here Miami
don't go girl let it work just selling
you me all right so you're getting kind
of messed up and I'm getting kind of
hungry so hold it together
all right you are though it's everyone
yeah you have I'm still reasonable you
haven't fallen out of the chair you are
kind of like you are kind of messing up
the autofocus on the camera because
you're kind of like I said I do but I'm
not doing that because I'm moving it's
happening cuz of psychic forces oh is
that what that is okay course now I got
the food heating up in the room yeah we
think for almost a two hours right it's
been a long show for people that have
been commuting or laying up in
man trying to go to sleep or whatever
they're like will you guys shut up the
other people that [ __ ] [ __ ] asses
already clicked off I'm subscribed if
you don't like it subscribe it will be a
much better place if everyone just did
that instead of complaining the comments
section the comments section and most of
youtube is like hell it's like
descending into hell
well yeah I read our comments but but we
got that's cuz we have awesome people
we got awesome fans and they come in and
go may get the [ __ ] out of here I mean
if I see one like I said I just deleted
that colorful in the weeds because like
here's the thing like I all the time
I don't watch a lot of YouTube because
I'm busy but it's like if I start if I
start watching something like for
instance I wanted to watch a documentary
about Albert Fish so I'm looking for all
the documentaries about Albert Fish like
if one comes on and I think it's stupid
or it's not getting to the topic I'm
just gonna click off in and get a notice
I'm not gonna like waste time making
this big [ __ ] I don't have time for
that [ __ ] it's like people that have
time for that [ __ ] understand you loser
I don't understand you it's like you
find something you like and that it's
useful to you it's like why waste your
time so many other good [ __ ] whining
about something you don't like employ a
good chance for a Brandon tunnelled
Brendan tunnel
I'm gonna go person he just posted a new
one in Canada do movie reviews
um he's Brad he's a big mst3k fans yeah
and then you got you got other represent
you got other ones like [ __ ] beer and
board games beer and board games and
welcome to the basement so that's
blatant blame society which the name of
the channel there that is actually the
only other channel that I gave money to
I love those got all kinds of cool
channels out there they're really all
over Harper all over Harper movie
respective British guy yeah he's got a
new blue red coming out soon
we made a documentary on Demetrio about
a bad action movies action flicks and he
did was it IndieGoGo or Kickstarter or
something like that he understands it
was from it was another time it was
another era I love all these like
younger because he's like a younger dude
yeah they could appreciate they're like
all super into like 80 stuff that's me
because you know when I was growing up I
simply you know my parents were like how
it's all people should although I like
it I like all that era was like a golden
age it's some ways in a way I know 7
News babies were golden age yeah alright
some [ __ ] I don't like about that time
for you alright so we're gonna stop
talking about Albert fish I hope we have
a different job I hope you haven't
depressed you have a depression if now
he's gonna come back and haunt you he's
gonna stick needles and you while you're
sleeping he's gonna do weird dude [ __ ]
wrong with them have a [ __ ] Alberto not
[ __ ] knocking well you just remember
that when he comes back to haunt you God
knock him out okay I told you don't do
it well yeah I'm pretty [ __ ] weakly
you know I mean he's going for little
kids and [ __ ] I'd [ __ ] knock that
[ __ ] out figure anybody don't like I
said anybody here's the problem kids are
a little animal ears the problem the
more you beat on our fish the more you
delay it that's what I mean there's
nothing you can do even when they said
we're gonna execute you he's like
batshit like tie Albert up put an apple
in his mouth and roasted melodicas Voris
always fantasize about he'd love that
[ __ ]
that's what I mean he'd be like alright
I'll make his fantasy come true though
there's nothing you could do to punish
him it's like he'd be like all into it I
heard and like I said I don't know if
this is true or not but I heard that
when they went to electrocute him he was
like helping the yeah the executioner's
like put the [ __ ] straps on him and
stuff like he was helping out like yeah
alright let's see how this goes right
yeah yeah that yeah I'll see you guys
what this is over so uh anyway so let's
wrap the show up hope you enjoyed the
show about Albert Fish which many of you
have requested so we finally got a rat
to its but we did it some justice no
we're both kind of messed up at the time
and remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show be much appreciated go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account if you would
like to give a one-time do
that would be super awesome and remember
our last movie review what the [ __ ] was
our last movie review a creep show to
you that we did so go check that out if
you haven't already and we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]